IKAI LAN: All right.
Eric is leaning over
right now.
Good morning, everybody, or
afternoon, or evening, or late
night, wherever you're
calling in from.
My name is Ikai Lan.
ERIC KOLEDA: And I'm
Eric Koleda.
IKAI LAN: And we are here today
to talk about Google
Apps Script.
This is a series of live
broadcasts that we're doing,
and you'll see that we've got
this fancy new studio now.
We announced it last time, and
I'm so thrilled to be here
every single time.
So Eric, what's new?
What's the word?
ERIC KOLEDA: It's been another
week in Apps Script.
I'd say the exciting revelation
of this week has
been there's been a blog post
out on using Apps Script with
Google Analytics combining the
two into a super awesome
mashup, which has really
gone viral.
I've seen tons of post about
it on Google+, on Twitter,
blog posts about it.
I think we're really meeting a
big demand here, which is that
people use Analytics, love
it, and they want to do
even more with it.
They want to automate it.
They want to do scripting
around it.
So that's been really huge.
IKAI LAN: I feel like this is
one thing we're totally
piggybacking off the
Analytics, because
Analytics is huge.
ERIC KOLEDA: Oh, yeah.
IKAI LAN: It's one of the
largest properties we have, I
would say, in the world.
And by pushing out this blog
post, we realize that a lot of
people want to do a lot
more with Analytics.
They want to take the product,
and they want to integrate it
with spreadsheets because you
might want to do custom
formulas and things like that.
And as soon as you get into Apps
Script world, suddenly
you can integrate with a whole
variety of Google APIs.
And I think that what we're
seeing with the blog posts is
really just the beginning
of a lot of what
developers can do with that.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
I mean, Analytics, I use
it a personally.
There's like a million and one
options of reports you can
generate, ways you can
segment data, right?
But even still, people are
mining even more information
out of there.
And with Google Apps Script, it
really allows you to build
custom dashboards.
We have dashboard functionality
and charts and graphs.
You can email out reports.
You can generate PDFs.
So really, it allows for people
to kind of customize,
down to the very nitty gritty,
exactly the data that they
want to see.
IKAI LAN: I really want to
encourage all of you out there
to take a look at this blog post
because we're trying to--
we'd love to see more Apps
Script applications in the
Chrome Web Store.
And I have a gut feeling that
tells me if you were to build
a really compelling application
on top of Google
Analytics, that you would
suddenly skyrocket to the top.
ERIC KOLEDA: That's
a good point.
I mean, building something just
yourself, that's great.
And it's going to
help you out.
But now with the Google Chrome
Web Store, you can really take
the work you've done, package
it up, and deliver it to the
whole world in a way that they
can just, one, click install,
and then get going with it.
I think the blog post this week
just showed how important
analytics are and how using Apps
Script in analytics can
really be a path to success.
IKAI LAN: So we've got a good
show for you guys today.
What we're going to do is we're
going to talk a little
bit about what's going on.
We've got a couple of questions
in the live
Moderator queue, so we're going
to go through those.
And after that, we're going to
take some questions from the
audience and just discuss a few
things that are going on.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
IKAI LAN: What do you
think about that?
ERIC KOLEDA: Sounds great.
IKAI LAN: We're acting as if
we hadn't planned this out.
But let's go ahead
and get started.
ERIC KOLEDA: All right.
So do you want to jump
to the questions?
I mean, I think we showed the
blog post already and talked
about that.
I don't know if you had
any other comments.
IKAI LAN: Not me.
ERIC KOLEDA: That was kind
of the big news.
So we normally have a release
every week, and part of this
show is talking about
the release notes.
But this week, quiet.
The release didn't really
have anything in it.
So we don't have anything, new
features to discuss or bug
fixes, but keep staying on top
of the issue tracker, looking
out for any bugs that you
reported, or new features
you'd like to see.
And hopefully next week we'll
be back with more
news on that front.
Let's jump into the Moderator
then and take some questions.
IKAI LAN: So I've done a little
bit of preparation.
I've looked at some of these
questions ahead of time.
So I've answered them in the
comments, but we're going to
go through these live anyway,
just if we want to elaborate a
little bit more about
some of the answers,
and stuff like that.
ERIC KOLEDA: Let me just get
that queued up over here.
IKAI LAN: While we're pulling
that up, I want to encourage,
if you get a chance to watch
our live Hangout, and we do
invite developers into
joining our Hangout.
But what we need to do
is on Google+ we
need to encircle you.
I think that's the
verb now, right?
We encircle you?
ERIC KOLEDA: Encircle, yes.
IKAI LAN: That's not
creepy at all.
It's not an official term.
It's just one that
we've been using.
But after we add you, let us
know that you're a Google Apps
Script developer, and
we will add you.
And when we do have these
Office Hours,
we can invite you.
You can jump on.
You can say hi.
We've got a couple of regulars
that jump on.
We love seeing you guys, and
we love talking to you guys
about what you're up to.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
I mean, obviously, if you jump
on, you're going to need a web
cam and a mic.
So if you don't have that or
you're not comfortable, the
Moderator page that we have set
up allows you to at least
get your questions out there.
IKAI LAN: Right, right.
ERIC KOLEDA: So we've got them
up here on the local machine.
We can't stream them live right
now, but let's go over
the first one.
So top here of the list. "Google
Apps Script describes
itself as working across
Google products and
third-party services.
But I don't see anything
concerning Reader." I guess
that's Google Reader. "Does
Google Reader support Google
Apps Script, or are there better
ways to augment this
service?"
IKAI LAN: So I was looking at
this, and we don't provide
Google Reader integration
at the moment.
I went looking to see
if we have a Google
Reader API, and we don't.
There are a couple of unofficial
ones on the web,
but the Google Reader API
is not really published.
So it seems like it's going
to be a little bit more
difficult, but I would encourage
you to file a
feature request in our issues
tracker, because we do want to
see what the demand is.
I mean, is it one person
asking for this?
Is it 200 people?
Is it 2,000 people?
That can really help us gauge
how important this is to our
developers.
I mean, in my perfect world, we
would have every single API
under the sun.
But unfortunately, there is a
limited amount of time, and we
want to get a few things.
We want to get the most
important things out there
before we start tackling a lot
of these other things.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
I think one of the things
about Reader is that it
doesn't have a lot of inputs
and outputs, right?
You subscribe, and
then you read it.
IKAI LAN: You mark as read.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
Short of that, I mean, I think
the API wouldn't be too large.
I mean, what is great about
it, and I actually just
reshared on my Plus stream today
something that someone
did, which is that using the
Google Apps Script content
service, you can now generate
your own RSS feeds.
And so someone today actually
created a very creative one
where they took the Apps Script
release notes page in
HTML, parsed it, and made
an RSS feed out of it.
So it's not interfacing with
Reader, but they did
create an RSS feed.
So it's kind of you can use
Google Reader as almost the
front end of some of your data
using Apps Script to
generate that feed.
IKAI LAN: I don't know.
I'll ask around.
I mean, the tech lead of the
Google Reader team is somebody
I used to work with.
They're based out of Sydney.
And every time I visit them, I
put in my feature request,
because Google Reader's a
product that I use many, many
times every day.
And I think Eric
feels the same.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
Wait?
You got to go to Sydney?
That's awesome.
IKAI LAN: Yeah.
Well, you just have to
ask if you can--
they've got a couple of
interesting teams out there.
They've got--
I don't know the teams
right now.
But they've got a huge
section of the cloud
engineering team out there.
ERIC KOLEDA: We'll have to
check that out, yeah.
IKAI LAN: And we had
a guy who was on a
site reliability rotation.
So one thing that you can do
when you work for Google is
that they have these
rotations.
And you'll see these
advertised.
And one of the rotations is a
site reliability engineering
rotation that you could do
for six months or a year.
And it's a very cool thing to do
if you're in an engineering
or tech role, because you can
learn a lot about what keeps
Google up, and how the pager
system works, and all that
good stuff.
So I would encourage you, if you
ever consider working for
Google, I mean, we are hiring.
So there is my plug
right there.
Now Recruiting can
get off my back.
But there's so many cool
programs here, and that's just
one of them.
And you get to meet a lot of
really great people when
you're doing that.
ERIC KOLEDA: That's great.
So next question we had
here was "Why does
contactsApp.getContact,
passing in an email,
why is it so slow?
It takes more than 10 seconds
to respond," this person's
saying. "Is there any way of
fixing this or working around
this issue?"
IKAI LAN: I took a look
at the specific issue.
Not his specific issue,
but I tried
reproducing this behavior.
Now granted, I spent about 10
minutes on this, but I could
not reproduce this,
unfortunately.
So my guess is that there's
something-- oh.
Hold on.
We've got a response
coming in.
This might be live.
Here we go.
This looks like--
OK.
So there's a couple of
things going on here.
This is not necessarily just
the Contacts application.
It looks like you're doing
something with
spreadsheets as well.
I don't know why this takes so
long, but I'll take a look at
this when I get a chance.
ERIC KOLEDA: I think I looked
into this previously when
someone else brought it up.
And for some of our APIs,
it matters how
much data you have.
So if you have a ton of
contacts, you may see
different performance
than other ones.
And I think it's just
a limitation.
And sometimes the way that we
fetch data, we kind of fetch
it all at once, and
there's not the
ability always to filter.
So I think we'll have to see.
It depends maybe on how many
contacts you have.
And perhaps letting us know
how many contacts you have
could let us better gauge what
the performance is like.
IKAI LAN: Right.
I'm looking at this
code sample.
One thing that would be really
interesting, really good for
us to do, is first off, I want
to completely separate
spreadsheets out of this, so
create a test application that
takes the spreadsheet out
and just uses Logger.
Because Logger is never
going to be slow.
But take it out and use this,
use this example, and use only
the line of code where
use getContact.
And furthermore, you want to
isolate whether it's this
specific contact, this specific
user, or your
specific domain.
There's any number of issues
that this could be.
I mean, we could just
have a data
corruption, which I doubt.
It's very rare.
But we want to narrow it down.
ERIC KOLEDA: That's
a good point.
I mean, we do a lot of work
on the issue tracker.
We're out there all the time,
and it's paramount that when
you do provide us with an issue
that you try to isolate
it as much as possible.
People give us their 100 lines
of code that touches a ton of
different services.
It's really hard for
us to figure out
where the problem is.
So take the time.
You're experiencing the error,
so you already have the
reproduction case.
A great way that we talked
about in the past--
copy your whole script, just
start removing parts until you
can still get the error, but
it's as small as possible.
That really helps
us out a lot.
IKAI LAN: Right.
I mean, I think that it's one
of these what we call n
squared problems, where it's
usually not any particular API
that's slow or bad.
I mean, if it is, it's very
easy for us to figure out
what's going on, because like,
whoa, there's one thing
happening, at least from an
external perspective.
But a lot of times when you have
two APIs interacting with
one another, this can cause
unpredictable things to happen.
And the more APIs we add, and
we're always adding more APIs,
the more kind of combinations
that we can have of things
that are going wrong.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
In some cases, there's best
practices around batching up
your request or batching up your
work that we can maybe
help with, too.
IKAI LAN: In this case, this is
a pretty simple call, so I
suspect it has to do with the
account or the contact that's
being fetched.
ERIC KOLEDA: That's
a good point.
IKAI LAN: But won't
know for sure.
ERIC KOLEDA: All right.
So the next one we've got on
here is "Is there a way to
iterate through all the comments
in a document object
and pull out only the unresolved
comments?"
IKAI LAN: I did not see
this question once.
This just came in.
ERIC KOLEDA: Well, I do know
that today, you're not able to
access these kind of
document comments.
These are the new ones that you
see in Google Docs that
they pop off to the side.
You can add new replies
as you go along.
It's got your little
face next to it.
So these kind of new dynamic
comments have only just been
added recently to Google
Spreadsheets as well, and we
currently don't support access
to them in either
Spreadsheets or Docs.
So I don't think that's going
to work out for getting the
unresolved ones.
At least not in Spreadsheets,
we don't support
them, I know for sure.
IKAI LAN: So I see a question
come in. "Any update on the
annoying empty logs issue?"
ERIC KOLEDA: That is
a popular one.
IKAI LAN: Which annoying
empty logs issue?
No, I know which one you're
talking about, the one about
logs on callback.
Yes, this is one of the top
priorities right now.
And I want to say that there's
good news, which is that there
are two things happening
in parallel.
One is that we are addressing
this particular issue because
this is stopping a lot of
developers, and this is
causing a lot of
misfired bugs.
I'm looking-- when I look at
issues in the issue tracker, I
see people say things like,
well, this API's not working.
I do a log, and it
doesn't work.
And well, it's working,
but it's not logging.
So I chase this down, and then
I go, and I'll follow up, and
I'll say, guys, please
fix this.
The second thing that's
happening is that we are
looking at overhauling the
logs infrastructure.
So that's going to be really
cool when it comes out.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah, they're
definitely working on
short-term fixes.
People want their logs today,
but we're also stepping back
and saying--
especially in the world of web
apps where maybe you have tons
of users using your
application and
you want to get data.
So we're stepping back and
rethinking a little bit about
how logs are done.
IKAI LAN: Right.
Right.
ERIC KOLEDA: And I guess in the
meantime, I think all we
can recommend, since the logs
aren't working in some of
these scenarios, is putting
your data somewhere else--
logging it to a spreadsheet,
logging it to a file.
IKAI LAN: Right.
It's really annoying, but there
are some people that
we've found out use this as
the workflow, and this was
part of the impetus to
overhauling the way we do
logging and the dashboard.
Because we found out in last
week's Hangout that we have
developers that, what they do is
instead of logging, they've
wrapped a class, and it's like
a log method, and they'll
email logs to themselves.
Because the nice thing about
this is that you get the logs
in semi-real time.
Whereas right now, there is a
bit of a delay between when
objects are flushed
to your log.
In most cases, it seems like it
happens after the script is
finished running, but I've
personally seen situations
where it's like a very
long running script.
It will be flushed
periodically.
ERIC KOLEDA: Oh, interesting.
IKAI LAN: So maybe I'm wrong,
and totally observed it wrong,
but I'll do follow
up about that.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
The email system is great too,
because the logs go away the
next time the script is run.
So sometimes people want to
persist that log information.
IKAI LAN: And to me, that's
telling us that there's lots
of places we can improve that.
ERIC KOLEDA: Room
for improvement.
And then we've another one
here, I think the last--
no, wait.
IKAI LAN: "Is there a way to
iterate through a contact in
the Contacts App Service for,
let's say, non-empty fields?"
So I tried a few things
to make this work.
I tried a couple of little
hacks, and I was unsuccessful.
So I would suggest that please
put this feature request in.
And I see why you would
want to do this.
Because I looked at the API,
and the API contains things
such as get emails, get
IMs, get phones.
But let's say you don't
want to exhaustively
go down that list.
You want to say, well, I want
to list these things out.
ERIC KOLEDA: Everything
I do know.
Everything that is populated.
IKAI LAN: Yes, exactly.
So please, by all means, file a
feature request, and we will
try to get that triaged.
ERIC KOLEDA: Sounds good.
All right.
So I think that pretty much
wraps up everything we have on
the Moderator.
Feel free, if you're watching
and not in the Hangout, to add
some more on there.
We'll keep going back to it.
But I guess now let's cut to our
Google Hangout, and see if
we have any live questions.
Hello and welcome.
LUCIANO: Hello.
Can you hear me?
ERIC KOLEDA: I can, yes.
IKAI LAN: Yes, we can.
Hi, how are you?
LUCIANO: That's great.
I'm fine, thank you.
That's my first time
in the Hangout.
I want to thank you all
for these sessions.
They are very helpful for us.
I have an issue where
I have created my
first dashboard script.
It is currently shared with
my friend who has
edit access to it.
This dashboard script, which is
owned by me, uses data from
a spreadsheet owned
by my friend.
I have edit access to it.
I tried--
I published the dashboard script
shared with my friend.
But every time he tries to
access it, he gets that page
where he has to request
sharing.
He's not able to see
the dashboard.
I have tried various
publish modes,
different publish modes.
Any ideas?
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
One initial thing that jumps out
at me, which is I've made
this mistake a lot, which is
when you publish something as
a web app, there's two
different URLs.
There's the dev URL, and
then there's the
fully published URL.
So the dev URL ends in /dev,
while the publish URL that
everyone can access is /exec.
So the dev URL is great when
you're building your script in
your web app, because you can
make changes and then
immediately see them
reflected.
However, for everybody else in
the world in the published
URL, it only serves
a certain version.
And so we have this concept of
versions now in scripts, where
you define a version, and then
set your web app to publish
with that version.
So I've made the mistake of
actually emailing out my dev
URL, which nobody
else can access.
That would be one thing
to check for.
Do you know if that's
the case, or if
you've ruled that out?
LUCIANO: Well, the URL I am
sharing is the URL that shows
on the pop-up box right
after I publish it.
I choose the latest version,
click Share, and it just shows
me the checkout.
This is the link for your
published script.
IKAI LAN: That's tends
to be the prod URL.
ERIC KOLEDA: There's a text box
that has the prod URL, and
then there's a link underneath
it that says click here for
your latest code.
IKAI LAN: Right.
LUCIANO: Yeah, that's the
one that I'm using,
the latest code link.
ERIC KOLEDA: The latest code
link is the dev URL.
IKAI LAN: Oh.
Yeah.
So the nice thing about the
dev URL is that it always
reflects your latest changes,
whereas a prod URL only
reflects whatever you pushed
out as the latest version.
So one thing to try is look
at the URL and see
if it ends in /dev.
And if it does, that's
the issue.
So look--
there's a text box, I
think, that has the
full URL with /prod.
Now, copy paste that, and
send that one out.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah, we should
probably clarify the language
on that page, because it's not
exactly clear that that latest
code link only works
for you, I think.
But, yeah, you want him to use
one that's in the text box,
not the one that's
in the link.
IKAI LAN: Right And to--
LUCIANO: Yeah.
That was the problem, then.
I will just try it right now
and see if it's solved.
But I was using the wrong
shared link then.
It definitely could
use a little
improvement in the writing.
IKAI LAN: So do you have a
separate account that you use
that you can share to test it
out, so you don't ask your
friend to open the script?
That would let you verify
it right away.
LUCIANO: Yeah.
I'm just doing that right now.
IKAI LAN: OK.
Cool.
LUCIANO: I'm very excited
about Dashboards.
I've dreamed about them.
ERIC KOLEDA: Google Apps are
making dreams come true.
IKAI LAN: I'm just really
glad that, you know--
LUCIANO: Well, yeah.
It's working.
IKAI LAN: There you go.
I think that deserves a
high five right there.
And we'll give you a virtual
high five through the internet
right there.
Boom.
LUCIANO: Thank you.
Thank you so much.
IKAI LAN: That's probably
a terrible idea.
We should probably never
do that again.
LUCIANO: Can I just go ahead
and ask another question?
IKAI LAN: Absolutely.
I mean, I don't think--
LUCIANO: If someone else
has another question?
IKAI LAN: There's someone who
has a camera turned off or
doesn't have a camera.
I want to make sure that
this person doesn't
have a question first.
ERIC KOLEDA: Is that
our producer?
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah?
IKAI LAN: Oh, is--
MALE SPEAKER: Oh, um, I just
have a question about maybe--
Let Luciano continue
and I'll--
IKAI LAN: You're a
little bit quiet.
Can you speak up or speak closer
to the microphone?
MALE SPEAKER: OK, I'll try.
Is this better now?
IKAI LAN: Hello.
ERIC KOLEDA: No, he's there.
MALE SPEAKER: Hello.
IKAI LAN: I hear him.
It's just-- hold on.
I have to turn our volume
up a little bit.
ERIC KOLEDA: OK.
MALE SPEAKER: OK, maybe I'll
try to plug in some
microphone--
IKAI LAN: Oh, we can
hear you now.
We just have to be
very, very quiet.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah,
we can hear you.
Go ahead.
Go ahead and ask
your question.
We'll see what we can do.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
I posted my question
on the Moderator.
And it's about the annoying
empty logs issue.
IKAI LAN: We just
answered that.
We are working on it.
It's a top priority.
So we have a little bit of a
longer answer, but yes, we are
working on this.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
Thanks.
I would wait, but I
couldn't hear it.
ERIC KOLEDA: Oh, no problem.
IKAI LAN: No problem.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
LUCIANO: OK.
My other question--
IKAI LAN: And before you ask
your question, is there
something we can call you by,
because otherwise, I'm just
going to call you guy,
or man, or person.
LUCIANO: I'm sorry.
My name's Luciano.
IKAI LAN: Luciano,
nice to meet you.
Welcome to the Hangout.
LUCIANO: From Brazil.
ERIC KOLEDA: Oh, great.
LUCIANO: OK.
So it's not really an issue.
It's just I want some tips on
how should I approach that.
I would like to have my
Dashboard to have--
when I change something in the
Dashboard, it would show some
new charts and hide other
charts, so I could have a
different perspective
on my Dashboard.
I didn't really go search that
on the web currently, but
since I'm in the Hangout,
I thought I'll ask how.
IKAI LAN: Sure.
So do you mean that--
what exactly are you
looking to do?
You're saying that you would
like some controls on your
Dashboard to change the views,
to show different widgets?
LUCIANO: Yes, I would like some
controls that change the
set of charts currently
displayed for
another set of charts.
ERIC KOLEDA: OK.
Yeah, I think that's probably
possible if you utilize some
of our UI app widgets, right?
So in the Dashboards world,
there are now these things
called controls.
And these are things like
sliders and category pickers.
IKAI LAN: Very cool stuff.
ERIC KOLEDA: And those really
integrate perfectly with
charts, but I don't
think you can get
other events from them.
I don't know if you can
bind to their events
and do other actions.
But you can certainly create
other types of controls that
have been around for
a long time.
So things like buttons,
radio boxes,
check boxes, tab panels.
All these different widgets
exist within the UI app
infrastructure.
So you could potentially utilize
them, where if they
select one radio button, you
hide a bunch of charts, or you
hide a whole panel
of charts even.
You can organize your charts
into a panel, hide the whole
panel, show another panel.
So all that should
be possible.
IKAI LAN: Right I think that
if you're not familiar with
building controls, a really good
tutorial that I've just
very recently done myself is
there's one about the Charts
API that uses different controls
for filtering by name
and age and weight, and
things like that.
And I think that's a
pretty cool one.
So once you do that tutorial,
you have a pretty good idea of
how to use controls to hide
and show different
panels in UI app.
So when I heard this question, I
immediately thought of about
20 different ways
of doing this.
And it's just whatever you're
most comfortable with.
Now, if you're comfortable with
UI app, that's probably
the way I'd go.
If you're more comfortable
with web development, say
JavaScript and DOM and HTML,
HTML service, this is fairly
straightforward to
do using JQuery.
But it's not straightforward
if you're not familiar with
JQuery and manipulating the
DOM and working with HTML.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
I think, unfortunately, one of
the limitations there today is
that the new Dashboard stuff
that we've produced for
charts, I believe only works
in UI app today.
IKAI LAN: Yep.
ERIC KOLEDA: With the HTML
service, we've talked about it
in the past Hangouts.
It works using this engine
called Kaha that does a lot of
sanitization.
And currently, Kaha doesn't
allow through other API
packages like the charts API.
So if you want to use the charts
Dashboard stuff that's
built into Google Apps Script,
I think you're going to have
to server through UI app.
IKAI LAN: Right, right.
And I guess that's one of the
trade-offs that you have to
think about making, which is
that using the charts API, you
can create like a blog and an
image, and you could fetch
that HTML service.
But now you're doing all this
work to do something that you
could have just done
in UI app, right?
So it's up to you.
But you do get more kind of
fine-grained control over how
it looks and how
it's laid out.
So there are various trade-offs
you can make.
But I do suspect that, like you,
Dashboards are great, and
I love that Apps Script lets
us build them very quickly.
UI app is probably the way to
go, and there should be ways
that you can make click handlers
do hiding of things.
And can you do this completely
client side?
Or does it also have
to go server side?
ERIC KOLEDA: That's a good
point, because in UI app,
there are the client
handlers, right?
LUCIANO: Well, yeah.
Doing it on the client side
is exactly what I want.
ERIC KOLEDA: Right.
LUCIANO: And I don't know
if it's possible or not.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah, I
think it should be.
There are client handlers
that are very limited.
You can't do as wide a
functionality as with the
server handlers, but you can, I
believe, change some styling.
You can, I think,
hide and show.
And you can do some other basic
manipulations using the
client handler, so you may
have some success there.
LUCIANO: Well, that's OK.
Thank you very much.
I'm going to look
into it then.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
IKAI LAN: You're welcome.
ERIC KOLEDA: I mean, to just
give us and our viewers a
sense, what are using
Dashboards for?
What kind of data do you find
them to be useful for?
LUCIANO: I'm sorry, I was
shutting off my phone.
It started ringing.
What did you ask?
ERIC KOLEDA: What kind of data
are you showing in these
Dashboards?
Like what is your use case, just
to give people at home, I
guess, an idea of what
you use it for.
LUCIANO: OK, I have a scientific
publishing house.
And we have many employees
filling out many different
spreadsheets.
And I'm trying to make sense
of the data we have.
So I'm showing different
reference styles that each
publication uses.
I'm showing percentage of users,
of employees working
with different publications
and stuff like that.
ERIC KOLEDA: Very cool.
LUCIANO: I am just
starting out.
I actually did use the tutorial
mentioned that shows
how many donuts people
have eaten.
IKAI LAN: That's a
very good one.
LUCIANO: And my first challenge
was to actually use
data from the spreadsheet
instead of the data that was
already there.
IKAI LAN: Right.
LUCIANO: And I'm very proud of
myself, because it took me
less than three hours,
actually, to do it.
But it was very fun.
ERIC KOLEDA: That's great.
IKAI LAN: Cool.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah, it's good
to see this new technology
already getting use.
It's only been out there for
a couple of weeks, and now
people are already using it to
kind of dig deeper into data,
which is great.
IKAI LAN: Right, right.
it's very cool stuff.
LUCIANO: It was a childhood
dream to do
Dashboards like this.
I tried Excel many times
but couldn't make it.
So I'm very thrilled.
IKAI LAN: One thing that's
really nice about Apps Script
is how easy it is to collaborate
on these things.
So once you create a Dashboard,
you can publish it.
And anyone that you want
to see it can see it.
So that's one advantage that
you definitely have over
something that's only
running locally.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
That's true.
And like you mentioned, the
time it takes to go from a
spreadsheet to something that
you can share is pretty small
compared to if you had to set
up a server, and all of a
sudden, get an environment
going.
IKAI LAN: And Luciano, just
imagine that your next
dashboard, you're going to be
able to do it in half an hour.
And the next time after that
it will be five minutes.
And over time, it's like seeing
this paradoxical that
will approach zero, right?
Where you'll be putting--
and maybe you'll break that
barrier where the Dash will be
built before you even
start working on it.
LUCIANO: Well, that's an even
older dream of just dreaming
about the code, and it's
just magically
happening in front of you.
ERIC KOLEDA: We can file that as
a feature request, I think.
The dream service.
IKAI LAN: That's gonna
get closed.
LUCIANO: That would be
very, very nice.
IKAI LAN: What will be really
cool is once you get really
good at doing this, you'll be
able to kind of realize what
kind of data you have, and what
kind of Dashboards you
like to show.
And you can generalize your
code so it'll work on any
spreadsheet.
Right now, the code is flexible
enough such that you
can go through all your
different types of
spreadsheets.
You can determine how many
columns there are, how many
rows there are, and roughly spit
something out that will
work for 90% of what you need.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
That's actually--
LUCIANO: Oh, yeah.
I was just playing
with that also.
I added a second row that
had the column types.
Some of them were int, the
others were string, and I was
just dynamically building the
table using the second row.
ERIC KOLEDA: Oh, yeah.
LUCIANO: But then I face a
problem that I was just
reminded of right now.
I was getting the invalid type
while creating on that loop
that creates the table,
the data table.
ERIC KOLEDA: Interesting.
IKAI LAN: Invalid type?
LUCIANO: I just got rid of that
row, and, well, left it
for afterwards.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
It may need some more testing
there and debugging to figure
out what that is, yeah.
IKAI LAN: I am gonna teach you
something right now that is
very dangerous.
But it is worth noting.
Oh, he's afraid now.
So it's something called eval.
But I have seen this, like this
is something that we even
use in a pinch now.
I use this sparingly where,
for our viewers out there,
eval is this thing that
takes a string, and
this string is code.
And it will execute this code.
So what I've seen some people do
is they've taken code, and
they put it into a spreadsheet,
and their Apps
Script will go ahead
and run this code.
Now, this is very dangerous
because untrusted code is--
so only use it on your own
spreadsheets, where you know
where the code came from,
or if you trust people.
Like if I built out something
that was accessing my personal
information, and I had an eval
in there, and Eric had access
the spreadsheet, he could go and
he could really just mess
things up for me.
But this is something that we
have seen people doing.
One thing that we were just
talking about a few days ago
was that sometimes people have
been doing this thing where
they will URL fetch, get some
code from the internet someone
has posted.
They'll fetch it, and they'll
eval the code.
And they'll run the
code that way.
Fortunately our developers
are--
I don't think we have too
many malicious people.
I don't think we have any
bad people, now that
I think about it.
Just knock on wood.
LUCIANO: Knock on wood.
IKAI LAN: So at least not
people who will publish
libraries, right?
But even if they did, you could
just look at the library
and see what it's doing.
But when we saw that a lot of
people were doing this, we
realized that, hey, we need
real libraries, man.
This is not--
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
IKAI LAN: This is not--
ERIC KOLEDA: We need a
full-time solution.
IKAI LAN: We can't keep--
this can't continue.
ERIC KOLEDA: So yeah,
we do have
libraries today too, right?
IKAI LAN: We do now.
ERIC KOLEDA: So now there's the
ability to package your
script into libraries, import
them into other scripts.
IKAI LAN: Right.
ERIC KOLEDA: Share
functionality.
IKAI LAN: Right.
ERIC KOLEDA: A little
better than eval.
IKAI LAN: Yeah.
But eval is an option, and
especially, we have one of our
mail merge scripts that does an
eval, only because it was
just easier.
ERIC KOLEDA: Yeah.
IKAI LAN: And only three people
were accessing it.
LUCIANO: Oh, yeah.
I'm gonna spend a couple more
hours on that, making use of
something like that.
It will help me also when I have
to add or change columns,
order, remove columns.
Being able to read the column
labels and just build up the
data table objects from
these labels is
definitely the way to go.
IKAI LAN: Definitely.
ERIC KOLEDA: All right, great.
Well--
LUCIANO: Listen.
I have one thing that I would
like to see that I
didn't find it yet.
It's some tutorial on laying out
these dashboards, how to
use the vertical panels, style
them accordingly, horizontal
panels, making it look
a little more pretty.
IKAI LAN: Right.
ERIC KOLEDA: So one thing before
we go on is that--
quick time check.
We are a little bit over time.
IKAI LAN: Yeah, we have to wrap
it up, but I think you
did bring up a good point, which
is a lot of our scripts
tell you how to get it
done, but not how to
make it look pretty.
I think we usually don't go all
the way to pretty, right?
A lot of our sample code, if
you probably complete a
tutorial, it's going to look at
a white background, right?
It's going to look
pretty boring.
And I think that's because it's
very subjective, obviously.
What's the best way to
organize your data?
It depends on what your data is,
how many charts you have,
how many controls.
So I would say start
experimenting, and if you run
into issues, that's definitely
where we can come in and help.
ERIC KOLEDA: And I'm sorry that
we don't have time to
answer all of your questions,
but we will be here again, I
think, in two weeks.
IKAI LAN: Yeah.
ERIC KOLEDA: Is it?
IKAI LAN: Maybe next week.
ERIC KOLEDA: Are we
doing that one?
Well, we are having--
we should be having one in the
next week, or two weeks.
Look on developers.google.com
for the calendar, There's one
that we might push back because
we are running--
again, shameless plug--
a hackathon in Austin, Texas,
on September 13.
It's a Thursday.
So for our viewers in the
Austin, Texas, area, take a
look on our blog, search for
Austin Apps Script Hackathon.
Now that I've got it rigged with
Google+, you'll see my
face come up.
I'm doing this.
So click through, and there's
a sign-up form, and we will
provide food and various
beverages.
IKAI LAN: Sounds delightful.
ERIC KOLEDA: Various
beverages.
Hopefully, we'll have lots
of things for you
to drink and eat.
And come by, and hack on Apps
Script, and meet us, and learn
some cool things.
We've got some heavy hitters
coming to that one.
I found out recently
that we have--
there's a tech lead, and there's
an uber tech lead.
And both of those guys are
coming out to Austin.
So for those of you guys coming
to Austin, you're in
for a real treat.
IKAI LAN: Fantastic.
Well, it's been great.
Another great episode, and we'll
see you guys next time.
ERIC KOLEDA: All right.
Bye, guys.
[MUSIC PLAYING]